you commented about
this thing about um you know the
generalizable skill and what what could
people do with olympia's afterwards so
that's actually my interest in the whole
thing
uh i don't i mean i don't
just coach students how to do problems
in fact i'm not even the best person for
that i'm not the best at solving these
problems
uh there are other people who are much
better at making problems and teaching
people how to solve problems
in fact when i was uh when the
mathematical association of america
which is the group which is in charge of
the u.s participation in these olympiads
when they were deciding whether or not
to put me in
back in 2013 as the head coach i had a
conversation with their executive
director
where i commented that we might do worse
because my position was i don't i mean i
actually didn't
want to focus on winning i said if
you're going to let me work with
60 very strong minds as picked through
this
system because the coach works with
these gets to run a camp for these
students
i said i'm actually not going to define
my success in terms of winning
this contest i said i wanted to maximize
the number of the students that i read
about in the new york times
in 20 years oh yeah and the executive
director
of the mathematical association of
america was uh
fully in support of this because that's
also how their philosophy is
so in america the way we run this is
we're actually not
just training to win even though the
students are very good
and they can win anyway one reason for
example i went and even did the covet
thing
involving quite a few of them is so that
hopefully some of them get ideas
because in 20 30 years i won't have the
energy or the insight to solve problems
we'll have another catastrophe and
hopefully some of these people will step
up and do it
and ultimately have that long-term
impact i wonder if this is scalable to
because that's such a great metric for
education
not how to get an a
on the test uh but
how to have how to be on the cover of
new york times
for inventing something new and i
do you think that's generalizable to
education beyond just this particular
olympia like
it's even you're saying this feels like
a rare statement
almost like a radical statement as a
goal for education
so actually the way i teach my classes
at carnegie mellon which i will admit
right away is not
equivalent to the average in the world
but it's already not
it's already not just the top 60 in the
country as picked by something
um let me just explain i have exams in
my class which are 90
of the grade so the exams are the whole
thing or most of the whole thing and
the way that i let students prepare for
the exams is i show them
all the problems i've ever given on the
previous exams and the whole the exam
that they will take is open notes they
can take all the notes they want on the
previous problems
and the guarantee is that the exam
problems this time will have no overlap
with anything you've seen me give in the
past
as well as no overlap with anything i
taught in the class
so the entire exam is invention
wow but that's how i go right my point
is
i have explained to people when i teach
you i don't want you to have remembered
a method i showed you i want you to have
learned enough about this area
that if you face a new question which i
came up with the night before
by thinking about like what could i ask
that i have never asked before
oh that's cute i wonder what the answer
is ah that's an exam problem that's
exactly what i do before the exam
and then that's what i want them to
learn yeah and the first exam usually
people have a rough time because it's
like what what kind of crazy class is
this the professor doesn't
teach you anything for the exam but then
by the second or third and by the time
they finish the class
they have learned how to solve anything
in the area how to invent how they
invent in that area yeah
you